Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house.
Christina
walks take pills at me.
I like that.
It's funky.
It's really a jam.
Yeah.
It's by a flutter and salmon.
Cool Song.
It's called Wacko.
He submitted this good shit.
Nice.
Thank you.
Better and salmon.
I love butter and salmon.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Um,
all right.
So check it out.
I am.
I'm out on the road genes doing things.
I'm flying all over the country.
I like to spread laughter.
That's always been my motivation.
Making people laugh.
I didn't realize that I have this whole sexy dad look going on.
Oh my goodness.
Where's your tank top?
You still have it on?
It's underneath.
I have an audition coming up.
A mom.
Mom should thank you.
Yes.
Um,
so
check it out.
I'm going to be in a bunch of places.
Homedale New Jersey,
Mansfield.
No,
that one got canceled.
Right.
Uh,
Long Beach,
New York.
Camden.
Uh,
let's see.
The white river amphitheater.
Auburn,
Washington.
I'm going to be in Woodlin Huntsman.
What does that woodlands,
Texas.
Dallas,
Austin,
Texas.
The shoreline again.
And uh,
the,
uh,
Irvine Meadows.
Amphitheatre um,
foreign high meadows.
Yeah.
Oh,
that I did ask it for the first time there.
really?
1992 Lollapalooza.
This,
that's exciting.
This is all part of the odd ball comedy festival I am doing.
Um,
all over the country.
Go to odd ball fest.com or [inaudible] dot com for tickets.
Everywhere is a bunch of comics are doing it.
Um,
different people in different cities.
So you have to look for specific people in,
make sure they're in that city,
but I'm doing all of them.
I know our friends,
Sarah t is doing some Tony with Bart Christ's word,
Joey G as Sebastian.
Uh,
Brian Regan's doing a couple.
Um,
all right.
Dane Cook's doing a few of 'em,
uh,
Ali Wongs doing a couple of them.
Um,
what's his name?
John Oliver's doing a couple of them.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
You ever saw
his comedy central to say that to me?
Oh,
really?
I'll mention it to him.
So I'm doing that through the first weekend in October.
Then I go to Charlotte,
um,
north cack a Laka.
I'm doing the comedy zone there.
Ben Cox comedy clubs,
and Manfred Disco California.
Uh,
Jude or titties,
Caroline's and doing that and the laughing derby.
And of course we added a third show at the truck and Philadelphia,
the cock and Philadelphia,
November 19th.
And um,
I'm also doing west palm in December.
The improv there.
So a bunch of dates.
Your mom's house,
you're going to podcast on all the rest of the year
to come back and baby jeans,
it's going to be like,
you know,
the worst part is people,
people don't understand when they go like,
Hey,
do you want to do something?
Like go?
I go,
I can't.
And they're like,
well,
when Kenyon like next year,
cause I go,
dude,
I can't,
I struggle with too crazy.
Yeah.
I don't have any time is all fucked up.
Um,
once you got jeans,
September 27 diamond Amit,
rattle Washington at the to come on your comedy club.
And then September 28th in Shortland,
Oregon at helium comedy crab.
October 4th,
Salus Terry Hos,
Hyenas and October 5th,
Austin,
Texas at the secret group.
Secret secret.
I'm tempered 23rd,
Indianapolis.
What does that one come on me map.
Come on.
Come on my ass.
Alessi an apple tips coming.
My asshole.
Intense.
Wow.
He got it.
Marty's comedy club.
October 24th Cincinnati,
Ohio.
Home of the notorious Cincinnati,
far at go bananas and then December 9th through 10th,
Washington,
DC at the DC Improv.
Buy Your tickets@thousandranch.com.
All right.
There you go.
Also,
Hey,
do you shop on Amazon?
I hope you do because if you're smart,
you do because we subscribe and save on toilet paper,
paper towels,
dog food,
toothbrushes.
I have that stuff sent to the house every week automatically,
so I don't have to shop for that crap.
Uh,
but use our banner on your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on it.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
It kicks back a little change to the shell.
Thank you.
All right,
hold on a second.
I know I forgot to put in something at the front gate.
All right,
you got the whole gay thing resolved now.
All resolved yet.
You know lady stuff coming from the pharmacy.
Oh,
oh,
appropriate.
You ready to start the show?
Here we go.
God dammit.
Dammit.
My pleasure.
Press spacebar and it doesn't go over there
from the last time you just one time.
Okay.
Dad gets so mad quickly.
Yeah.
Okay.
I can't wait until your son starts watching you get angry like this.
All right.
We're going to laugh at you so much when he's older we go angry.
Dad's getting for no reason in that.
Funny.
My name is Casey Tech,
former Kraft of us from Melbourne and I'm up in Darwin doing a performance piece
casting off.
I'm spending 28 days from will that I've inserted in my vagina.
You're not ready,
Christina.
She's got answers.
Starbucks.
Yeah.
I can't start with scissors.
Cornrow hairbrush.
Use that marker and well,
I'll use a sharpie to stir my coffee.
Yeah,
cares.
Everything goes in my mouth.
Anyway.
This is why my immune system so strong.
True.
Cause I started my coffee with the sharpie.
I guess that's more your lane.
I'm more of a water guy.
Fuck off.
How don't you dare look what I did fresh.
Okay.
I wonder who ordered that bottle of water for you because you certainly didn't
obtain it yourself.
You're the mom of the house.
I'm the dad of that.
That's true.
Moms,
moms driving.
So I've so many questions about this.
Number one,
how do we keep it in there?
It doesn't it rub it raw.
It's a pull yarn out of your snatch and 28 days worth.
Well,
or does she replenish the supply?
Let's get some answers.
I need to know.
A lot of my day I take
that's been wound so that it will unravel from the center.
The staff,
I stick it up inside me and I pull out the and smell
it.
Now you've been knitting,
this is last year and a half.
Well,
this is,
this is the Zealand way.
Where's she from?
She's,
I'm sorry.
This is the Australian method.
I use the Canadian.
I'm from Melbourne.
Yeah,
Male Bun.
This is how the the Malbournians do it.
I prefer the method.
Yes.
I put an entire Spool of yarn in my age
and it's confining because I'm attached to this.
So get off and wander around.
Yeah,
you can't really,
it's restrictive.
It's not painful.
I mean not the English,
the abs out of there.
So it's kind of put his dry,
he robust area,
but it's got to feel like sandpaper cause that that yarn doesn't look very soft,
doesn't look soft,
it doesn't look silky smooth.
It looks like it feel course on your little event.
Cause sometimes when you pull out a Tampon it rips it.
If you pull it out and it's dry,
I'm just letting you know and that's cotton.
It can,
it feels like it's tearing out your vagina.
Well when you're doing the knitting from your asshole,
does it hurt?
It's
juicy in there and lubricated.
Fresh.
Natural.
That's got a smell.
Not good though.
Her,
her yard or
all Brown.
You're yarns the word.
What do you live?
What are you talking about?
Cause I smelled that monster fart.
You dropped crazy.
Now just to be fair,
that was sick because I had diarrhea yesterday for the first time in a long time
I had a seventh two sevens in a row.
I felt like I had to sleep like that joke of yours where you feel like you have
to take a nap after a dumb.
I was like down for the count,
man.
That's intense.
So this is her look how proud she is.
Very bad.
You know what?
I think part of the reason she's proud.
Um,
not a lot of people that are the,
that come up with an idea or they feel like this is a truly original and that
evokes this.
There's no one has done this.
I guarantee there's nobody on planet earth doing this right now.
But her,
it's like when you come up with a really good joke,
she thought of that so pleased with herself.
So pleased.
Yeah.
That's good.
So she's been performance wouldn't pay the performance.
I don't know if it's a pile of like going to cut out menstrual side from that.
Assad is
a hell of a lot harder because I'm going to fucking
Yank Kevin.
I knew that was coming.
It was just filling me with so much anticipation and joy.
Look at that.
Yeah.
I mean I've seen that before.
I get a period myself.
That is what the Tampon scarfs.
I don't knit the tampon strings.
That's what I'm wondering is why not just collect your tampon strings and then
make a tapestry out of,
but she likes to go fresh.
I get it fresh on the scene.
It's intense.
For our listeners who can't see this,
it's pretty spotty.
The yarn and certain points of it.
You know what though?
There's this whole movement to stop period shaming.
I think I told you yesterday about those.
I'm not trying to period shame.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying that this is kind of a timely art project to this woman's doing
because there's this movement now to take the shame out of women's menstrual
cycles.
Like there's panties you can buy now,
but you can like free bleed in them and you don't have to wear a pad or a Tampon
and you just like let it rip and these underwear.
And then he just watched it and they're like super absorbent I guess.
But they look like regular panties.
So I mean it's a lot.
It's quite a lot.
Quite a bit.
Yeah.
I don't know if I'd want to share my menstrual cycle with everybody and a form
of a scarf.
You know what,
I would prefer to see this kind of like performance on.
Let me tell
you guys the best.
What do you think he's up to today?
He's probably doing something with duct tape.
His performance.
I put duck tape up my,
I asked,
can we watch more?
Is there more of this?
I'm so intrigued.
I love it.
I love this chick.
It sort of slightly uncomfortable
arousing sometimes when I'm sitting in the gallery,
people say,
you're so brave.
You're so brave,
and it feels really
natural.
I Outerwall he's put yarn in my pussy,
man.
Straight uneventful.
I think the administration does.
Maybe the,
maybe the,
maybe the knitting with it.
I can't feel natural.
I don't know if I could,
I mean,
I dunno.
That's one word for it.
I don't know if I could bleed in front of strangers.
That would be the only part.
When I'm sitting in the gallery and meeting,
I get a lot of the reaction is people say,
you're so brave.
You're so brave.
Brave men wheel whatever.
Tensions,
duct tape pads,
intense.
A lot of crazy lady
expectation.
Wine drinker shine.
What made you vomit more?
You're a drinker or pussy.
Blood.
Urine drinker.
Yeah.
Cause Pussy blood.
I'm used to,
I've,
I've birthed.
Yeah.
So you've seen a lot of stuff come out of me.
Tall person came at one time.
Yeah.
And then all the junk,
the cam comes out after him.
Yeah.
Stitching up and there's cutting in that.
This doesn't,
I the only thing that bothers me as a thought of putting course yarn up my
vagina and then pulling it out a lot.
Like I just don't think it's,
that feels good.
Yeah.
When you,
you know
our son.
Yeah.
Uh,
duct tape.
Yup.
Our son duct tape.
Yeah.
I wish doctors were there to duct tape me together.
You were all,
it was all fucked up.
I fucked up.
And then the doctor's like,
I don't know what to do.
And I was like,
that'd be shut in Doug's table.
Be My neck.
My obstetrician.
Yeah.
Duct tape.
Huh?
Tape.
I think the expectation when you're shining the vulva that people are going to
feelings of fear and repulsion.
So by linking the vulva with something that people do find warm and fuzzy and
benign,
anything boring meeting,
long period of time.
I hope that people question the fears and negative associations.
They have like a nice lady.
Yeah.
I'm interested.
That'd be friends there.
It'd be interesting to meet her and be like,
uh,
she's like,
what are you doing tonight?
And be like,
Oh,
you know,
just got to Melbourne and probably is going to make it easy.
I'm performing.
Oh yeah.
Where's your show at this gallery.
Okay.
Maybe I'll stop.
What are you doing?
That's interesting.
Yeah.
She thinks that her shoving yarn up per coach and then having her period on that
yarn and then knitting with it live will alleviate people's fears.
Yeah.
About anything as opposed to terrify them.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'd say this scares.
They get terrified.
We're going to 51 50 tonight,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
you know I'm a French strokes,
different.
Same Strokes,
same strokes.
Everybody's the same.
A man that was a good one.
It's really good price and I'll do it.
Yes.
Soy,
Yardley fade.
[inaudible].
That's a Norwegian.
Burt Chrysler is fat.
Throw that out there for people.
That was good.
People submit it in different languages and we always like to reward them.
Um,
so much talk about jeans.
First of all,
we should be mentioned to a,
our Patriot petitioner,
patrion listeners,
patrion.com/a mom that we are releasing the live episode from flappers,
uh,
on Patriot on later in the week a five gets access
to the backlog of bonus episodes,
rewards offered at different levels every first of the month.
Really Scans of our notes from the month,
desktop wallpapers.
And we also release a poster.
Many of you got the Cincinnati far poster commemorating the infamous Cincinnati
Fart.
Many of you have seen the documentary film that 60 minutes made the little
teaser that kind of revisited the Cincinnati Fart.
And that poster went to a bunch of people that subscribe on Patrion.
So please subscribe to patrion.com/mom and got all the extra bonus stuff.
And yes,
live episodes are definitely going on.
Patrion don't bust my fucking balls about it.
Um,
I,
there's a bunch of proof that it needs to be there and not as a regular release.
And that is because we released live episodes,
uh,
over and over and over on our regular channel.
And you know,
even though I enjoy them,
you enjoy them and some people do.
The masses prefer the studio show.
It's fine.
I don't blame them.
Okay.
Don't blame him.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Um,
we got a bunch of feedback on a retarded stuff.
Yeah.
I'm really thank you for all the emails letting me know what it is that retarded
people do all day.
It's definitely a retarded.
Yeah.
When you say people retarded,
so there's a whole bunch of,
you want to get into a,
there's emails,
there's um,
you know,
cause videos.
Yeah.
I'd like to hear,
give me an itinerary.
I read through a few of them and a lot of them seem to be very similar to what
we were proposing.
An average day.
Well,
it's all came out of your question.
Your question was what do retired people do all day?
Yeah.
And,
uh,
we discussed that at length and then a lot of listeners volunteered.
Um hmm.
But I am genuinely interested and curious and I,
I,
I do want to know,
and I,
I feel like retarded people have been marginalized in our society.
I feel like you saw them more when I was a kid in the eighties remember on facts
of life,
there was a comedian character who I don't,
I forget what would she had Trudy.
Yeah.
No,
it was her name.
Trudy is not her name.
You know,
tying,
my shoe was a standup comedian and she had some kind of different,
the facts of life.
Yeah.
What's her name?
Trudy's or was that the big girl?
Right.
The big,
isn't that her name?
Natalie.
Who is faxing?
You think about Rudy,
not a Cosby show.
Trudy.
Here.
Let's see.
Okay.
Here's the,
she wasn't not retarded.
No.
She would keep Jerry.
That was her named Jerry.
She was Dan comedian and she had some kind of problem.
I don't know.
Oh,
we didn't see them a lot more and there was a whole life goes on.
Life
goes on.
There was a TV show starring a retarded person and,
and that was kind of a norm in the 90s.
And then it's like retarded.
People just disappeared.
And you used to see them working in grocery stores more?
I feel like,
yeah,
like growing up I always see them pushing carts or bagging groceries and now
like you never,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I feel like there was more of a push to accept them and society in the past.
Even that word,
you know the word retarded,
right?
So from 53 to 73,
um,
the,
the club,
the organization was called the National Association for retarded children.
And then from 73 to 81,
it was called National Association for retarded citizens.
And then from 81 to 92,
it was called Association for retarded citizens.
Arc 92 and now.
Yeah.
And then they change it to the arc of the United States.
And they said like,
hey,
they said it.
Here's it says as the terminology,
the words,
uh,
um,
the met the term mental retardation remains the terminology used in the medical
field,
right.
Reference in many state and federal laws,
however,
intellectual disability and developmental disability or making their presence
known,
and we're doing everything in our power to make sure they're adopted more
broadly.
So it means somebody retarded that's still like if somebody goes,
he has an intellectual disability.
What you like,
what he's retarded,
right?
I mean,
we can,
we can flower up the language,
but exactly.
At the end of the day,
I don't think it ultimately helps,
you know,
I don't think so either.
And I don't think there's anything wrong with being retarded or we'll give.
Okay.
You know,
it,
um,
they used to medically use the term moron.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
I know.
Or,
or a mongoloid.
Yeah.
Idiot idiots.
A little severe.
I think
idiot proceeded Maura.
But yeah,
they,
in the early 19 hundreds they used to be like,
he's a moron.
Zamora.
Yeah.
That just means stupid.
But to be retarded means to have a thing that is held back to retard some things
progress.
Right,
right.
So maybe it's fire Ricard mentally.
Correct.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
I don't know.
I,
we grew up calling.
Yeah.
Retired people were trying to,
yeah.
See these temp jobs.
My job,
I learned the job slow kind of.
Now I know it by heart.
He earns money.
He pays taxes.
He's just like you arc the Association for retarded citizens.
Yeah.
Don't throw us away.
See that's what I was saying.
That's how it's been playing since I got it though.
Yeah.
Can we press pause and address no technical issue.
Oh,
you mean the file?
Yeah.
You'll see this.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Cause I liked this commercial because it brings up the point.
I was saying that you don't see retarded people integrated in society.
I feel like anything
here it goes,
my job is the job slow.
I know it by heart.
Yeah.
See earns money.
He pays taxes.
Yeah.
Good for him.
Just like you arc the association for retarded
citizens,
everybody needs to feel important and have a job in life and a function.
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
Well,
I wouldn't say he's just like me,
but
he's got your hands down before I go potty.
But he has her glasses.
He did have my glasses on.
But you're right.
I think there's a little more like hidden.
You don't see them in society.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know why they can't.
Why?
You know,
I think baggers,
grocery baggers and cart pushers should be,
yeah,
the grocery bagger back where I went in Florida and school,
they were all uh,
you know,
disabled guys.
Yeah.
Good job.
It's a fun job.
It's funny.
He's always do this to Charles.
Um,
so the guy would bag our groceries and then at this place they walk you to the
car.
They put them in the car for you.
So when he put them in the car and he'd walk away,
my mom,
good,
thank you.
And I'd be like,
mom,
there's something different about that guy.
I would play it real serious.
Did he seem like a little offer?
Something?
She like dummy.
He said.
And that's the thing about people that have English as a second language.
They don't move along with the Times as terms of rat a PC watering down.
They don't do it because they just learn a word.
Like that's the word.
Yeah.
One of the hardest I ever Lau.
It was like fucked up and it was,
you know,
almost mean,
but it was so innocent on her behalf.
One of her friends had a son who had like some severe mental disability and she
came over to the house and the kid was like older than me,
so he was 30 when I was 20 right.
So we're at the house and she's like,
oh,
you know my friend Roxie her,
yeah,
she has to go do this thing.
She just to take him somewhere today.
And I'm like,
just take her son somewhere.
And she goes,
well you know,
and her friends right there.
And she's like,
yeah,
I have to do a lot of things for him.
And I was like,
oh.
And my mom goes,
her son's retarded.
And I was like,
and I like in the middle of a conversation,
I just walked into another room and I was like,
and then she came in,
she's like,
I know you are laughing.
I go,
he just called her son retarded to her face.
And she's like,
well,
and I go,
it's not that cause I was going like on the other actors.
Like you can't say that because right.
And then right away Roxy was like,
ah,
he's a,
she goes,
he has a learning disability.
And I go,
oh,
okay,
okay.
But I just,
I lost you set.
So anyways,
here's uh,
one of the emails we got.
Hey guys,
huge fan.
I wanted to give you a few fun facts about what people with mental disabilities
do during the day since mommy jeans was curious.
I used to work at a center here in Vegas that provides job placement and
training for the disabled.
Tommy's correct.
Tons of sugar.
You would see a lot of them walk around with two liters of soda in their hands
at all times.
Yeah.
They don't have that mechanism,
but then take it away from them.
A lot of them drive themselves to work every day.
Keep that in mind.
I kind of got a crosswalk or on the freeway,
uh,
the majority live in state funded group homes with or with their parents.
They fuck like rabbits anytime,
anywhere.
But if you have down syndrome,
you are sterile.
So there's that.
The majority of them are smart enough to know that they are mentally disabled.
Oh.
In my experience,
my experience,
there were several male employees who when they were walking towards the
restroom,
which start dropping their pants around their ankles well before they entered
the restroom and when usually come out at the same time.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
Um,
it's interesting.
Every time I saw a naked man with down's syndrome,
he had a massive hawk every single time.
Love the show.
Keep up the good work.
Gabriel.
Thank you,
Nailed it.
Sure.
God,
I hate that they're eating so much.
Should you have another email you want it to read?
No.
I want it to share though.
I have a,
um,
I don't know if he's retarded,
but he's,
he's a slow,
my cousin Chubba in Hungary.
He came to stay with me like I was a teenager and my dad tried to teach him how
to fix forklifts and stuff.
And my dad was like,
I think jumbos would have thought it did.
Yeah.
Because his parents had that blood type saying we're two people of the blood
type,
shouldn't have children.
And that was Chubba and he's in his forties and he lives at home and Budapest
and he rides his bicycle around the city and he looks for Ufo.
Yeah,
he's different.
he's touched.
That's all he does.
Yeah,
he,
he believes in aliens and he's trying to find it.
He loves to ride his bicycle and he bakes and stuff like that.
Like so I mean,
you know,
he's got a job in a bakery contributing.
He's got a full life so that's cool.
Um,
here we go.
Mommy's,
I'm the librarian at a special needs school librarian at floor in Florida.
I work at the school for over 10 years and I've seen some shit.
My girl is a high school teacher and work through as well.
We love your show.
I have to say,
I envy our students,
honesty,
brutal honesty and some cases their total lack of inhibition.
I enjoy their company more than most people.
If anything,
there are a lot like you always doing is saying hilarious stuff.
I see Tom is coming to camp on,
maybe I can find him an opener.
Lol.
Um,
also watch out for special kids.
They have Pika Pica,
Pica,
they eat everything.
I,
because when you eat like chips on the wall and you eat dirt,
are you?
Oh No.
I said don't.
Were you pulling out your,
I don't know.
It's either you pull out all your hair or you eat.
I think it says,
like he said,
I've seen one slam a gallon of water in record time.
Okay.
So you maybe maybe retarded guys.
The water champ that's we should look for.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Mommy's,
I'm writing in a listening lab.
So regarding daily life as a retard,
my wife worked as a live in caregiver for two women who were retarded.
Uh,
both,
I believe in their forties old for a retard,
right,
Tina?
Yeah.
There I'm old for a retard.
Their day,
however,
was not all been licking,
been flicking and sugary treats.
Ladies were up early,
had a day program.
They went to find odd job places,
went on field trips,
learned skills that might allow them to one to live on their own.
Then they would go home,
go for walks,
watch TV,
dinner.
Oh,
I'm sorry to inform you that it's not all day old donuts in porn marathons.
It's actually pretty boring and much similar to the life of maybe a grade school
kid.
Yeah.
Okay.
Interesting.
Andrew.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know what's interesting too is when I had diarrhea yesterday that I felt the
need.
Now tell me if you do this.
Yeah.
It's like a weird thing where when I have diarrhea,
I'm sorry.
This just caught my idea,
my eye that an actual retarded person just wrote it.
Not really.
I don't think it's really real.
Go ahead and read it.
It says,
my name is Mike.
I want to tell you about an average day for me as a 28 year old retarded person.
Okay.
Before I begin,
I want to be known that Tina is the main mommy.
See,
I think it's a joke.
Oh,
okay.
You read that one?
Yeah.
Okay,
nevermind.
Go ahead.
Let's talk about you're having a thought and I really wish she would respect,
I'm sorry,
I just caught my eye.
Okay.
So it's a very important subject.
I had diarrhea yesterday,
as I said twice,
and I felt the need to strip down.
Yeah.
Like I had to take off my pants man anywhere and I wanted to take off my shirt.
I know those completely naked.
They're not even date their night,
weekly,
once every few months.
Those dumps where you're like,
I got to change.
I've got to get naked and why do I have to get naked before I like,
what is it that like you have to
going to battle.
You're know you're going to war.
You know why?
Where are your good clothes?
Don't want any Sunday best.
You're about to go wade through us
dorm right now.
I just feel like I got to get clothes off of me.
Like when I'm in pain or something.
I know exactly how you feel.
Yeah.
Oh,
it was so weird.
Big Shit.
By the way,
speaking of this,
uh,
disabled people's inability to control their sugar intake.
Do you have a contribution?
Yeah,
I kind of broke down on a,
I had an incident.
You put gas in the car?
Yeah.
I don't know what happened to me,
but this morning I dropped the dogs off at the groomer and then I had to put gas
in the car and like I went inside to get some hand sanitizer because I fucking,
well every time you pump gas,
you know your hands are dirty.
Yeah.
It makes me crazy.
And I know this about myself that I love those sour straws.
Now there's a bunch of other candies that are sour,
but these are my favorites there.
Strawberry in the apple sour punch straws.
Yup.
And so I bought a pack of each and,
and then I devoured both of them.
And it's 11 in the morning.
You must have really crushed it too.
I don't know what came over me.
I was
like,
I,
and um,
when I start opening and I eat those packages,
I have to have the whole package too.
It's really bad.
Today is day five for me with no sugar.
How are you feeling?
You actually feel pretty normal now.
Really.
The first 48 hours to 72 hours of the worst.
You are grumpy.
Saurus yeah,
I know.
Sorry.
He went to get a facial with the Russians.
Yeah.
And feel good.
You look great.
Um,
it was really bad.
It was really bad.
The nose was just filthy.
I don't wash my face.
Yeah,
I know.
So you just don't wash it ever.
Yeah.
I told you what to use.
Did you use it last night to wash your face?
Um,
that's a no.
Yes.
No,
no I did.
I didn't use that one.
I use the one in the shower that you said is not the scrub.
The other one.
Yeah,
the salt.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
So then you went to ended the Russian lady go like,
you're really fucked up.
No,
she goes,
there's room for improvement.
You know the one thing I didn't realize about facial,
because I think I've only done it one other time is uh,
how much theirs,
they're just not there.
How much calmer frizzly come on.
Like six guys telling your face softens the skin.
Yeah.
And then they're like,
open your mouth,
open your mouth.
And you're like,
oh yeah,
I thought it was just from my face.
Well you can open your mouth.
It's not mandatory,
but that,
um,
she's like,
okay,
like sets you up,
rubbed something on your face,
puts the steamer here.
And then she's like,
I'll be back.
Yeah,
I know.
And you're like,
all right.
And then she just leaves for 10,
15 minutes.
It's Freaky,
right?
Cause you're like,
did she forget about me?
Yeah.
Then she comes back.
Okay,
let's see.
Okay.
And they put that but mirror or not the mirror,
the glass over.
You look at the magnifying glass.
I want that man.
Yes,
I have one.
You do?
Oh yeah.
All girls do.
It's our secret.
It's your secret.
It's my secret.
She did she give you a nice little shoulder rub?
Uh,
not really know what you're supposed to get.
One while your face gets steamed.
Um,
Babe,
what?
We had another retarded email.
It just came in right now.
Okay.
Hi.
Hi Tom.
Zero High Push Trina.
Okay.
It's not a retarded person.
I'm a big boy who goes to a fun school.
I have friends.
Okay,
stupid.
So dumb.
He says,
I don't like,
I don't like correct Christina.
Budzinski her jokes are too hard.
My teachers like her.
I think Tom is funny.
I like Tom,
my friends like Tom.
I see you're the retarded people's comment.
Yeah,
you're right.
I've told you this for so long.
When are you going to go and make your act retarded man.
Anyways,
I appreciate all the input,
all the interesting things everybody told us about this.
Yeah,
that was interesting.
I never thought we'd go down that tangent,
but we did.
We did.
Yep.
And I liked the,
uh,
the,
that some retarded people know they are because that was a big debate for us in
that infamous,
would you rather that I dropped months ago?
Would you rather be retarded or get jerked off by your grandfather on the Ferris
wheel?
And the big problem was whether or not,
you know,
if you're retarded and now we know that some of them,
some of them do know.
Yeah.
Some of them do know.
Speaking of,
God dammit,
this is it.
An angry,
it'll look at him.
So we,
a few weeks ago I was hanging out with Matt full shrine and Mike Cronin after,
uh,
shows in Columbus and somehow we're just talking about football.
I think it just prompted me to pull this guy out.
Fucking asshole.
Mark Davis,
the son of legendary owner and coach Al Davis of the Oakland Raiders.
He inherited about $500 million.
Wow.
And um,
that's what it looks like.
That's what he does.
And the crazy thing is,
I guess people rightfully give him shit constantly.
Yeah.
The bulk cut.
Right.
He drives 500 square miles to get his haircut and like that five.
So he seeks it.
He goes to the only person 50 each way.
The only person in northern California willing to give him a terrible haircut.
Yeah.
You know,
one time my mother went to Allen when she was alive and ask for it.
Vidal Sassoon Cut.
Yeah.
I want short on one side,
long on the other.
[inaudible] and Allen let know she must've got mad.
She got furious.
A Fuck Helio mother fucker.
What you're fucking piece of shit.
Mexican did the,
yeah,
she said that.
Yeah,
of course.
She was out of her mind.
My mother.
And what did he say to that?
And then you know,
he figured out she was crazy and then that was that.
That's the last time she saw Alan and I have been seeing him for 20 years.
But yeah.
Anyways,
that's why,
because there's no hairdresser that should do that to you as an adult and that
is terrible.
Oh my God.
This is why you shouldn't be alone.
This is why nobody should be alone.
He doesn't have a wife.
Right.
Or a girlfriend or wife.
Bachelor.
I've gotten worse.
Yeah.
No woman would let this.
I'm like,
get your life Mark Davis.
You guys got to see this guy.
So Google,
Mark Davis.
Yeah,
that's his dad right before he died.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Runs in the family,
Huh?
Yeah.
Not a bunch of lookers.
These people.
This is a one of my favorite stuff.
Expression.
Yeah.
A lot of people will bring up a Lloyd Christmas,
you know from the,
yeah,
that's what it looks like.
It's a perfect bowl.
This is my favorite picture though because of,
look at the way his arm lays in his crotch.
It lays real special.
Right?
It's weird.
Yeah.
And the teeth are bad.
He's got bad veneers.
The reason I started yeah
posting is cause I laughed so hard.
This,
this guy did,
a guy did his,
I guess Halloween costume where he got a wig.
He got the shirt.
But the best part is he laid his hand super retarded.
Oh my God.
That made me laugh so hard.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
Now do you think,
I think he might be slightly autistic or asked what was wrong with them?
I mean,
first of all,
you know,
he's a team owner and he looks like,
like I still like he won a scratch off and was like,
dude,
I got the sunglasses.
I'm balling now.
Um,
it just looks,
he looks out of his mind.
He a,
he drives a minivan still like a,
like a 93 caravan has a flip phone.
You know,
like probably there's some aspect of him that's like,
oh,
I'm not,
you know,
I didn't earn being a team owner.
I think he's probably,
that's interesting and secure about that.
That's my own theory,
but I'm now,
the hair's definitely really bad man.
There's no question about it.
Again,
I think this is what happens when you don't have a woman loving your life.
A woman,
and he's a lifelong bachelor and he's probably a little socially retarded.
Yeah.
Like I said,
maybe Asperger's,
autistic or something.
And there's,
there's definitely things going on.
Jesus.
I know.
Jesus Christ.
If there's a sign,
well,
it's just the time to,
you know what you do.
You go no more public showings no more.
This is what I look like put.
I'd be like,
no,
no dude.
Don't have a big screen.
And we watch the game from here.
Howard Hughes at that point you were reckless.
Why?
Like don't leave the house.
Jesus Christ.
There's a bandaid on your face that's a real fucked up man of lesions
and the blood doesn't,
he'll know more.
Just Ron,
I know you guys stay inside.
Okay.
It just take me as a game.
Nobody wants to see you.
We've got real crazy.
And his older days,
uh,
Al Davis.
Yeah.
And he used to like,
he was an owner and coach at one point and then he would,
you know,
he was the guy that always,
he would draft players based on measurables.
In other words,
if they ran really fast in the,
in the 40 yard dash timing and they jumped really high,
it'd be like he'd be like draft him and they were like,
well we think this guy's a better player,
that guys fast draft them.
So they would just draft these like really impressive guys that are on,
on when you look at the numbers on the measurables.
But then they would be,
you know,
not as good of players.
And he would also,
they said he would call down to the box,
like he'd be watching the game and the owner's suite and be like,
throw the bomb.
Like,
just go deep.
And they're like,
we got to have a really,
a little more sophisticated,
uh,
offense to throw the bomb.
And they're like,
all right,
they would just run plays that he forced them to work.
No,
no,
no.
He's like,
but I own the team.
I'll that the fuck I want.
I mean they,
I don't blame him.
You knew that if you,
if you were working for him that he was definitely in charge.
There was no question that the Raiders that used to be an la team is crazy.
They know there's a big push for them to go to Vegas.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
That is a perfect fit for that team because the Oakland Raiders,
the fans are terrible.
Well,
the NFL will have to pretend to be in shock,
uh,
and remove them distance themselves from the reality that the NFL is gambling's
biggest cash cow.
Oh,
you know,
so that's the NFL is like what in Vegas is like,
yeah,
dude,
they're going to Vegas and you have no problem with it because gambling is what
keeps this business alive.
I mean,
NFL is thrives on the fact that people gamble every week,
tens of million,
hundreds of millions if not billions and billions of dollars.
Fantasy football is all about gambling.
It's all about money.
You know,
their,
their sport is tied into money and they're like,
we would never want it to be in Las Vegas.
Why?
Yeah.
That's the best place in the world horse.
It is the best place,
especially for those animals who love the Raiders.
Yeah,
yeah,
it does.
They're so hard for,
man.
I posted those pictures and every,
every fourth or fifth comment was like,
fuck you bro.
California and their writers,
man.
Yeah.
Our intent.
It's also like the gangster team,
all gangsters,
gang bangers who love the Raiders,
who love the record.
I want to,
I feel like that did start in soquel because growing up here,
yeah.
Gangbangers war,
Raider Shit and Lowe's lawyers.
Right.
Those are our two teams.
Yeah.
And then when we lost them,
I think like the hardcore gang bangers,
the nor cal ones took it over.
Yeah.
Let Asa,
what's the like in the prison gangs?
They,
yeah,
it's different.
The northern California ones,
the prison gangs are different.
Prison gangs are totally different.
Those guys took it over.
Yeah.
They always,
black and white was always a,
uh,
you know,
that was the,
the colors adopted by,
do you know if you were like,
oh,
I'm a gangster.
You were black and white,
so you could wear Oakland Raiders.
You could wear a Chicago white sox because that's black and white.
That's what those uh,
like Nwa guys always had radar stuff on white and stuff on,
you know.
That's right.
Oh,
white socks,
Huh?
Yeah.
Just because,
I mean,
you know,
it's funny.
Well it's also the white sox are on I guess,
is it south side of Chicago?
So it's a little more,
it's more hardcore.
Like the cubbies are,
are,
you know,
more like the affluent team,
like I'm down your white sox fan,
you know.
Okay.
Yeah.
Say what should their own times ago.
Okay.
Oh right.
But then here of course,
all the blue and red teams to yeah.
Be careful with the blue and the red teams.
Yeah.
Cause the crips and the blood affiliations.
Growing up in La,
I couldn't wear a red or blue to
junior high school public school because of the gang affiliation.
Popular colors,
really popular,
which would have been like,
you know,
spout Orange Sienna and chartreuse shit you never wear,
I don't wear two of the most popular colors.
Stupid.
And British Knights.
You couldn't wear those because they were bks blood killers.
Stupid crips wear all the time.
Yeah,
I'm blood killing.
There's this other thing that the trainers,
the bloods do,
I guess crips do it too.
So if you're a blood,
you don't,
when you write,
you don't use the letter c because that's considered the a blue band shaking.
He say,
how was the crib?
So they'll use like the letter x k or be yeah.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Wow.
He really hate those Kreps Huh?
Yeah.
No,
it's how loyal are you man?
Hello?
You are you into this nonsense to nothing that means anything.
Yeah.
Um,
listen,
I have a correction for the last episode.
I said that my father drank 75 beers in one sitting.
That is not correct.
I remember he told the story.
It was between he and Willie together.
They drink 75.
Yeah.
So sorry guys.
My father is still an alcoholic.
Rest assured,
but just not,
how did,
um,
what made you,
what prompted this?
Remember,
I was like,
wait a minute.
Did I say that he did and I,
that's incorrect.
They,
they,
it was he and Willie.
Now Willie,
he's dead right from that,
from that day.
Uh,
but my father,
your dad drank basically over 30 beers in a day.
Correct.
Alarming.
And he's so proud of that.
Yeah.
You know?
That's something to be proud of.
I'd like to do an outing like that with a buddy,
you know,
go somewhere and drink a lot of beers.
Like try to try to set a record.
Yeah.
You have a friend that you're going to tour with pretty soon?
I don't think I would,
I don't think it's going to do to do it on tour.
I think it'd be a vacation thing.
You know,
like,
Hey,
there's,
there's no shows.
Let's go do this.
How many beers can you drink?
I Dunno,
I'm not a big booze bag.
So,
um,
you know,
I think if it's like easy light beer kind of goes down.
Uh,
we're talking to over the course of a day.
I don't know man.
Like,
think of your vacation,
like,
you know,
you start drinking in the morning.
We were in Mexico.
I remember what you were saying.
This is different though because with this thing we're talking about,
if I'm trying to do that,
you approach it differently than casual vacation because vacation you might
drink a few and be like,
Oh,
you know,
put your effort toward effort towards it.
That's interesting.
They could set up something where um,
you know,
I know to a location and a date,
we'd try to get people there and we all try to drink as many beers as we can.
It's a really good idea.
Yeah.
And it's positive for the community.
I can't,
I can't drink more than four drinks a day.
Tolerance.
You've never,
I've never seen you really go for it.
Get ripped.
Never.
I just don't,
you know why?
Cause there's a vomiting factor and I have a real fear of vomiting.
So with liquor stop pushed it before,
but then I don't remember what happened.
I blackout,
which I know is healthy.
So I've done that a number of times.
I haven't seen you drunk drunk and you said you were drunk at Ellis is baptism
party but I don't,
yeah,
but not like really,
really.
I mean I was just like so tired that one drink had me feeling like I got fade
it.
Huh?
Yeah.
No I haven't done that in awhile.
I have,
I have had uh,
I'm trying to think of the last time or really boosted it was funny cause I was
ripped too cause we were both so exhausted.
That was a tough week.
And I had like one glass of wine and I was like,
and there's pictures of us at the pictures of us when were ripped.
We're all shiny and red holding ls like my,
my thing.
Usually once a year I overdo it with liquor,
drinks,
you know,
liquor drink.
What do you like to drink?
What does my drink Scotch sometimes vodka soda is like my outdrink right.
Cause it's easy goes down low sugar boy drink.
Yes.
Low Sugar.
But those you can get in trouble with if you really,
if you keep ordering them,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause you forgot we don't taste the alcohol after a minute.
And then when you just realize,
oh I just write half a gallon of vodka.
Yeah.
So the beer is way easier because much lower alcohol content.
So I don't know man.
We should,
I should try that.
I should try.
Yeah,
I think you should get into this.
I think a good thinking.
I don't know.
I'm thinking maybe you set a goal of like 20 beers and just see if I can,
I think Burt can,
Oh Bert,
obviously.
How many beers do you think Burke can drink in one day?
If we really were trying to go for it and we're doing,
maybe you just pick like he'll say his favorite beers.
Heineken.
Yeah,
that's my dad's favorite team or a,
but Miller Miller lite.
It's Kinda like sickle cell with weed.
Yeah man.
I haven't done it in a long time with them,
but the last,
like years ago I would go over to his house and he was like,
you wanna smoke.
I'd be like,
no,
I'm good.
And he would roll.
He would smoke an entire joint and tire joint of like,
you know the good California medical shit that's done.
Light up another one.
Then he'd be like,
blah,
blah.
Totally normal.
Fully functioning.
Let's go.
No problem.
And I was like,
man,
if I'd smoked like a fraction of that,
I'd be laid out on your couch right now.
You wake me up tomorrow.
Oh yeah.
And I can't smoke in front of other people.
Yeah.
I can only smoke pot alone now.
It's been a minute since I've touched this stuff obviously.
But yeah,
I don't like I get,
I get really self conscious and I don't,
I don't like it.
I'm not the type that likes to smoke with other people.
Yeah.
I only like it if in socially at like it in very small doses.
I think it all comes down to tolerance.
You just have a low tolerance.
Oh yeah.
I've always been.
So if I'm with people I want a little bit,
if I'm alone I can do a little more.
But then I spent a lot of time,
uh,
yeah.
To be a better person.
Yeah.
I know.
I start analyzing everything that's in my life and where,
what I'm not thinking about,
I don't like it.
Oh,
I need to think that much.
And they were married.
My name is [inaudible] and we will be attempting the longest cheer.
Boy is cute.
I know.
He's adorable.
I will feel just seeing him go.
Don't get surprised.
Alright.
Okay.
Yeah.
Turn that shit down.
Yeah,
he's attempting the longest.
You have boy ever.
I didn't know there was a thing.
Good know either.
He's winning so far.
Yeah.
Wow.
I'm still here.
Wow Man.
What a talent.
Wow.
Really proud of you.
Good job.
Good work.
And that was really good.
And yeah,
everyone's got to town.
I don't know if you actually have the record,
but in my heart you're the longest.
Yeah,
boy.
Ever.
You know,
you know,
um,
uh,
we were talking about a baby names.
Yeah.
And we decided that a really good name if we were to have a second son.
Yeah,
we'll be Carl's Jr.
Yeah.
Carl's Jr Carl's jr cigarette.
Yes,
because I,
I ate a lot of Carl's junior people ask me,
how was your son so strong and big?
And our son is as big as the one year old,
like a wallet,
a Carl's junior almost every week.
And I had an extra onion rings and extra barbecue sauce and I'd park in the
parking lot.
And that's why he's so big.
That's right.
There was a time when I was eating western Bacon cheeseburger is twice a week.
Yeah.
And then in and out every day.
I just love the idea and about 50 pounds people having to say the name
correctly,
you know,
because I can picture us doing that and then people would be like,
Carl and I'd be like,
it's Carl's Jr.
Don't ever forget the apostrophe.
And don't forget the junior.
It's Carl's junior.
His name is Carl's Jr.
Like the restaurant.
Yeah,
I like the Western Bacon cheeseburger.
I eat a lot of them.
It's like Ruth's Chris Steak House.
But I would like to name our son Tom's Ruth's Chris.
There's too many possessive.
It's such a,
you can't do that.
It's so dumb.
I remember explaining it to you because you were a little bit,
where the fuck are we eating?
And I was like,
Ruth's Chris.
You're like,
what do you mean by Ruth's Chris?
And so the best way to explain to people that don't know about this steakhouse,
picture it this way.
It's Chris Steak House.
Okay.
It's Chris is a pro.
It's no,
no,
no apostrophes.
No,
no,
no.
The wrong.
It's just called Chris Steak House.
It's okay.
So C H R I s steakhouse.
Chris Steakhouse.
Okay.
Ruth bought it and she wants people to know it's Ruth's Chris Steak House.
And understand how long's the reus?
It's possessive of Ruth.
Ruth apostrophe s Chris Steakhouse.
Ruth's Chris Steak House.
Yeah.
Got You.
Okay.
Now if we name our son coms Ruth's Chris.
Oh Shit.
That'd be cool.
Tom's and then they're like,
what's up with that dumb fucking name?
You'd be like my eyes.
My husband loves steak.
We ate there the week that we almost dangerous.
Tom's Ruth's Chris.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
Don't you feel like somebody should've pulled Ruth aside and like,
Hey,
this is a dump.
Why?
Why are you doing?
Why don't we just leave it Chris,
they,
I bet you there's just like a divorce thing.
Like,
like Chris was the husband Chris Steak House and she's like,
it's mine now.
Fucker and then she's like,
it's Ruth's Chris Steak House.
Somebody looked this up and tell us.
Yeah,
I bet you that your divorce.
I bet you too.
Or she wanted to keep the brand of Chris Chris stick.
Now here's the thing,
but hold on.
Hold on.
Yeah,
but Chris stakeouts,
I don't think that's correct either.
It should be Chris's steakhouse.
Correct.
Tony's restaurant.
There needs to be a p apostrophe.
Chris apostrophe steakhouse house.
Don't you remember?
Dammit.
It's Hinchcliffe cliff.
Yeah.
His Dad's was like Joe.
Joe.
Joey restaurant.
Yeah.
Joey Italian restaurant.
Not Joey's.
He's a pot.
Right.
That's what,
that's what this equivalent of is Chris Steak House.
Yeah.
It should be Chris's dude saying,
okay.
Over four decades ago,
Ruth Fertel,
Jesus Christ,
a divorced mother to mortgaged her home for $22,000 to buy a small 60 seat
restaurant in New Orleans named Chris Steak House.
Shortly thereafter,
a fire forced her to change the original location and she renamed the restaurant
Ruth Chris Steakhouse.
I told you.
Yeah,
it's so dumb.
It's so dumb.
That adds nothing to the brand.
Nobody cares about Chris.
They only care about Ruth.
I know.
And it's a great restaurant.
I love me some roofs.
Oh,
it's great.
It's great.
Yeah.
Nah,
that's what gave me diarrhea yesterday is that other steakhouse.
We would just think for lunch.
Yeah.
And I had the cream spinach and I think that's what did me,
and I think it had too much butter in it.
Butter gives me diarrhea sometimes.
Um,
do you want to hear Ruth's recipe for life?
Sure.
Insist on making a toast.
Oh,
make big plans but live spontaneously.
live and dine without regret.
It's nice.
Oh,
with Oh Ruth's.
Tom's Ruth's Chris Thomas.
Ruth.
Chris.
Get in here.
You do your homework.
Tom's was Chris.
Go to your room.
The I like Carl's Jr Siguro much better at Carl's Jr is really good.
Yeah.
After western making cheeseburger.
Your mom's favorite.
What about waffle house?
I like the waffle house a lot.
There was a lady named Cherries Tennis Waffle?
No.
Yeah.
Cherries.
Tennis waffle.
Yeah.
What does that even mean?
Cherries.
Tennis.
Waffle waffle.
Cherries.
Tennis.
Um,
she was arrested.
I know because,
uh,
Harry had the world is a horrible place.
Tennis waffles.
Yeah.
She was arrested.
I remember,
cause Ryan and I were doing this pitch and look.
Oh,
cherries,
waffles,
tennis.
Those are her student.
Jupiter,
Jupiter.
It's a weird place until you say police safe.
Tennis was arrested.
They wrote,
had to,
I had to write it as a regular article.
Cherries.
Waffle tennis.
That's her name.
There's also crystal Metheny.
Oh boy.
Bees out do,
do that.
But he'd be bop,
Bop,
bop.
I liked za but he'd be Bob.
Bob,
Bob.
That's uh,
that's somebody that changed their name to that,
you know,
obviously to like for attention.
But I think she might've been named Cherries.
Waffles.
Tennis.
Yeah.
Silly Sherry's waffles.
Tennis.
Hit in here.
Yeah.
That's good or bad.
Their three favorite things.
Yeah.
I think it's parents,
but then tennis is kind of a Bougie sport.
I don't know.
Too many hillbillies.
I Like Cherries,
waffles.
And then tennis.
Mm.
What will we have named them?
Uh,
our kid fart.
You love raspberries though?
I love raspberries.
Raspberries,
stakes.
And what's our favorite sport?
Sitting?
I Dunno.
Naps football though.
I like,
Oh,
you like football?
Yeah.
So raspberries,
stakes,
football.
Get in here.
It's pretty good.
Roots Chris's called junior sit down.
I still like Carl's junior and that's the dumbest name.
There you go.
If we have another son,
Carl's Jr will be his name.
Speaking of rednecks being dumb and stuff like that,
what do you think of this?
Neighbors along patents spur road are still well buzzing.
Know about what happened?
Well,
I had got done fighting my chicken,
watering them and stuff and I walked back from Ohio.
Hi.
Start Day.
Yep.
My phone tracker play a video game on it now.
I wish I hadn't.
I heard a big boom Alec back out my door.
And electric power fail and lands are filing and the heel cacklers Sab.
Why?
He's into the fence.
What?
What was he in there?
I don't know.
Did you understand?
Well,
the master of accents is always got his ears open.
Um,
I need that.
You've found an American sample?
Yeah.
For our,
our friends abroad across the pond.
This is how dumb we can be.
Yeah.
Lauren electric power fail lands have fallen and a GL cacklers Sab.
Why?
He's into the plants.
The jail tagger sideways into the fence did did to jail.
Tackers jail.
Attackers know the jail.
But that's cheap.
But that doesn't sound
lands the fallen,
the lines have fallen that Geo cacklers Sab.
Why?
He's into the fence
and the jail tackers sideways into the jail.
Tackers that's fucking retarded.
Yup.
My door and electric po fail aligns with filing and the GL cacklers sideways
into the fence.
That's so dumb.
That doesn't make any sense.
Jill.
Taggers and [inaudible].
That was fucking,
that is a real person too.
Yeah.
He didn't know it at,
but he found out that there was a hive of bees that was located there and he
disturbed them.
And I was a guy come up squish griming Esquire Allen [inaudible] and I'm running
around.
Hold on by lack of speaking with,
hey,
cut out the hat.
Yeah,
that's eight,
eight.
Didn't we learn that?
What that stands for?
H h the h letter of the alphabet.
How Hitler.
This guy's a fucking Nazi guys.
Does that surprise you?
Why like
a,
uh,
it looks like a Nascar Hat,
right?
That's what I thought it was.
Oh,
you don't think it's a Heil Hitler.
let's see.
Does anybody drive with a,
is anyone sponsored by Hitler on the Nascar Circuit?
And we know how to ask maybe Dany Mac knows I'm NASCAR driver.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Earnhardt Jr.
Oh,
why wouldn't they be?
He's a Nazi.
Yeah.
The eight,
eight stuff.
Street yarn.
Heart should know better than that.
I mean,
maybe they're like fucking finally dude.
Like,
yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Goodness.
Oof Man.
Since she wished this was your dad,
how lucky that you're,
that's not your dad.
My Daddy.
Do you ever sing in that?
Sometimes like I'm just so glad radiate.
Hey,
how I held her down.
Yeah,
that is good.
You of course.
It's a few people's dad.
Yeah.
Yep.
Oh,
okay.
I want to own up there and he found out,
well,
you filed by a half of bees there.
Bleed.
Disturb them.
Wow.
No one talks like that.
Super.
It's like a Disney.
Are you in a squabbling?
He has dip in his mouth too.
Yeah.
Permanently.
Surgically implanted.
Yeah.
And uh,
how ruining your ring,
that lack of chicken with hey,
cut out leaky down.
Bang,
don't brine.
It's embarrassing.
Did says they ran up the road,
grabbed a hose outside his home and started trying to spray off the bees.
I told him I need to get out of water,
but I didn't know is getting eat up by age.
I thought we'd just high what?
I understand what he said.
Oh right.
It's crazy that this guy lives in our country.
Yeah.
And talks like this.
I know.
It's fucking insane.
It's MD Anderson didn't says they ran up the road,
grabbed the hose outside his home in stock.
So the people that were covered in bees grab this whole trying to spray off the
bees.
I told them I need to get out of water.
So I told him,
you need to get out of that one.
I didn't know he's getting eat up a age,
but he didn't know that the guy was getting eight,
eight,
eight up with bees.
Stung by bees.
My Butt ate up with bays at Ruth's Chris steak hat.
Carl's Jr get over here.
Oh,
he just ha ha.
I thought it was just Ha.
Oh,
okay.
So he thought they were acting a fool,
right,
because they were just really high.
Gotcha.
You understand that he wasn't aware of the bee problem?
Yeah.
Yup.
Exactly.
Deputies say the couple were under the influence of drugs.
They say they had driven,
they were hacked.
They were.
Ha.
Most people are that live in these areas.
What else are you going to do?
[inaudible] got no hope.
They were high.
The road looking for a place to swim at narrowing a little McCain and Jesus
Christ.
I thought,
Oh,
here.
I'm sorry
it got that one.
I definitely don't know.
And you can see whatever it is in his mouth.
Look at that again.
Looking for a place to swim in your own little bikini.
Yeah.
She had her red dots.
Oh,
here.
Do you understand that?
Yeah.
The girl in that Bikini Red Bikini,
she's knitting a scarf at an answer.
That was pretty good.
That's pretty good.
Yup.
Looking for a place to go.
Looking for a place to swim.
I've known that little bikini.
She had a little red dot.
Oh,
here.
She had little red dots all over.
There you go.
Oh Wow.
Look at you.
Blue bands,
the hillbilly whisper.
How did you understand that?
Yup.
That's it.
You speak fluent hillbilly.
I've known him a little bikini.
First language.
She yellow red dot though.
Oh,
here.
Yeah,
she had girl and that little bikini.
She had little red dots all over.
Yeah.
Wow.
You could,
um,
you should move there.
Fit Right at the FBI.
Would red hair.
I ain't never seen.
No one would have got him before.
God.
Do you think they're tolerant of Jewish people?
No.
Right for this.
I think it's probably in America it's probably the last pocket of nonsensical.
You don't see like a,
I mean,
in La,
you know,
this
is a Jewish city,
so you don't really see that.
But I mean you,
when you hear it,
you're like,
what are you talking about?
But I think deep,
deep southern really biblical places are probably the last project.
Jew.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Probably because they,
it's like one of those things where they're,
they're never around it.
Even when I would do the south,
they would see my last name on the marquee and I was an outsider.
Yeah,
for sure.
I know I'm like a white blonde.
Oh No,
I'm a big outsider.
Yeah.
No,
I don't look out.
I don't think you see it a lot higher.
Crown was a foreign.
Okay.
Yep.
Wow.
Uh,
uh,
of all that could have been your dad,
like,
do you just think of the probability of your life,
the,
the fortitude that you were born with your parents and I know not in like some
horrible country.
When you think about it,
you're like,
turn that down.
But that was the whole toy.
Horrible.
Alright.
Bring back duct tape.
Duct tape.
Duct tape dad right there.
That's how he saw that.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
that's for duct tapes from,
yeah.
So good.
Oh Wow.
I don't know.
Um,
so I like to bar.
I liked the part.
Yeah.
Okay ma'am.
That's kind of the song I've been working on.
I like to fight.
I've been singing my song more to Ellis.
Mommy,
Mommy.
Mommy is the best
daddy.
Daddy,
daddy doesn't care about you.
Not Cool at all.
He loves it.
Yeah.
Anyways.
Um,
here we go.
Or is it,
Mommy.
Yeah.
Yup.
Did it in junk,
gentle,
gentle update.
Oh Man.
I gotta go.
I gotta go to,
what are we doing this?
Okay,
let's find a new dentist and the neighborhood.
Yeah.
And go get our teeth cleaned.
Maybe we should go towards the new,
yeah,
my health,
my old Hungarian dentist was,
oh,
I remember I neighborhood.
He's retired now though.
He's retarded.
He's
retired.
He shouldn't be working on,
I think it's pretty advanced.
Uh,
dearest mommy's,
I used to cringe
or fast forward when you did dental updates.
I knew I had been neglecting my choppers.
Why?
It had been at least eight years had been to the dentist or life.
I had no dental insurance and frankly,
I was poor.
I had begun to smile less because I knew my teachers.
We're looking less than awesome as terrible years of smoking,
which I quit four months ago.
Congratulations.
Coffee and no flossing.
All of the signs of bad tooth ownership.
I'm coming up on my wedding and a few weeks.
Oh.
Mortified at the idea of having to do anything at a tiny smile for all the
fucking pictures that will be taken.
Yeah.
I made the appointment.
Yes.
Five days before my wedding.
Oh,
what if there are issues.
The Nice lady took note of the nuptials and when they got a cancellation,
she called me.
I had my appointment today and what did the email my mommy's and let them know
the results.
Yeah,
no cavities.
Wow.
But a few very,
very minor issues from my hard brushing habit and lack of flushing,
flushing,
flossing.
Everyone in the office was Super Nice.
No one made me feel bad about not being to the dentist.
They all wanted to help.
We have a plan for the future.
I will forever be a patient at this office.
Just wrote them a thank you card and put it in the mail.
I will not stop smiling and looking at my sparkly teeth.
Good for going to feel great about myself.
The day I marry the man of my dreams and it will show in my smile.
You guys pushed me to do this.
I thank you.
Always going to floss from now on.
I promise the Kate the hygienist.
Thanks Eric.
All right.
Nine graduations.
Good for you.
And you see how that works is that he says I have no money.
This is a man writing this.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Okay.
And,
and they,
they worked out a plan.
Yeah.
Payment plan.
So guys,
don't let money deter you from fixing your teeth.
They'll always have more.
Um,
you know,
empathy for you when you go in person.
Oh,
funny.
What's worse?
Because there are people too.
And the thing is don't think you need dental insurance.
Tom and I don't have it.
I haven't had,
I had it once in my life and that's when I got ripped off.
Remember the dentist told me I had about 20 cavities.
Tom,
if you recall,
that happened to me and I don't have dental insurance anymore because of that.
True.
Yeah.
Oh,
by the way that they even pay.
He's distracting.
What do you mean?
I said that it happened to me when I had dental insurance.
They told me I had like 20 cavities.
Yeah.
And then I,
you know,
I canceled it happened to me.
Yeah,
I know.
Now you're admitting that it did happen to me.
You claim that it didn't happen to me.
That what happened to you did I went to a dentist with dental insurance and they
said that I had 20 cavities.
Did it?
I know,
I know.
You always take my stories and make them yours.
But um,
there was another thing.
Oh,
you did this to,
you did it.
You did the other,
you did it the other day.
It took something that happened to me and you're like,
oh.
But to me,
uh,
it was for the first,
Oh my God,
for the first three months that our son was alive.
Yeah.
And every time I would burp him,
I would burp.
And you'd go,
Jesus,
why are you burping ever?
You're like,
it's so,
I don't understand if,
if you're burping him,
why you have to Burp.
And then you go,
hey,
you know what?
Every time I burp Alyse,
I have to Burp.
And I go,
I know you gave me shit for this.
You don't have no recollection.
You said to me every day and you're like,
nope,
never,
no,
no recollection.
Anyways.
A lot of the dentist did that to me and I burp when he grips.
So I have no recollection of the first three months of his life.
And you don't remember me telling you the dental story of of,
but that did happen to me to ask my friend,
Eric,
do you remember me telling you that that happened?
And I remember who it happened with.
The TV,
TV friendly dentist.
Yeah.
See,
I do remember yours.
And then the same thing happened to me in sperm bank,
California when I had dental insurance for,
from an employer I had.
Okay.
I swear I don't,
I don't,
you know,
I know that you live,
but the thing is,
by the way,
I still floss despite these ridiculous stories that flossing doesn't help.
And didn't you tell me the other day how philosophy does help that it breaks up
bacteria?
No,
you told me clusters of it,
right?
Somebody told you that it wasn't me that told you.
Okay.
Yeah,
I remember the brain.
Mommy,
nine guys.
It's real.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm talking about the poop pile.
There's no bull shit with your pupae and email that came in about the poop pile.
Hey,
Mommy's,
I was listening to the powerful Jre Joe Rogan Episode Two oh seven when I heard
something Amaz Joe steps away briefly around one 1845 while he was gone.
Red Band tells you guys he has a new game for you.
He was game to see how long can go before flushing the toilet.
Mommy,
Tina is not on board,
but the water champion mentions he already did something like this in college
and it was called by.
Since Tom had no reason to lie at the time.
I believe this is massive evidence that he has been truthful the whole time.
Giving the Yorkie sippers already married track record FedEx,
and look,
Roy,
I think it's easy to see that the poop pile did indeed exist.
Tyler,
thank you for your message and you will be receiving a prize anyway,
by the way,
the poop pile is different than not flushing the toilet.
Yeah,
okay.
The Poo piles at varsity level,
not flushing and an outdoor pile that you claim people pooped on it.
It wasn't a non fleshing.
Do you remember?
We don't flush a lot in this house.
One that's yellow.
We leave it mellow.
Yeah.
Each other's yellow sun sometimes.
Especially at nighttime.
Yellow you got to flush that every time it's a waste of water.
The water and sound it going just yellow,
yellow,
yellow.
7:00 AM you flushed it?
That's my answer.
Cause there might be four or five yellows in there.
If you remember.
We played the,
uh,
I've been yelling a lot at night.
I think I have to stop drinking water a couple hours before bedtime.
I would never do
anything like that.
So,
but I hydrate so much throughout the day,
but I pee all night because I'm hydrating so frequently.
Yeah.
When you get used to the high consumption like me,
you'll get past it.
I want you to note,
yeah.
I had some eggs removed from me.
What,
what we talked about this.
Okay.
So I had some eggs.
Frozen embryos frozen.
Yes.
Just in case we want kids later.
Anyways,
they told me that I can't drink water from 8:00 PM the night before the surgery.
Yeah.
Until the next day.
I thought for sure that would really be a thing for me.
Yeah.
But because I'm so hydrated,
it didn't even bother me.
Oh actually the doctor pulled me aside and told me that you were super died.
That's a lie.
Yeah,
that's true.
Remember when you had your blood taken?
Yeah.
And she's like,
I can't find a vein cause you're so dehydrated.
Your blood was thinking coagulated.
Find a van cause you're so fat.
It's not that all the fat is covering it now.
She goes,
your blood is like chocolate syrup.
Why is that bullshit?
Cause you're not hydrated.
Bullshit.
You remember we watched that I'm Dennis Rodman thing.
We talked about,
hey broke his dick.
Yeah.
Blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Says Ah.
Yeah.
So yes.
So
I love him so much.
You know,
I have a lot of empathy for that guy.
I think he's a good man at his core.
He's just,
he's fucked up.
He's got,
yeah,
sweet guy though.
So here's a listener who I believe says they broke their deck,
right.
Oh,
get their mommies having been there.
Uh,
excited cowgirl.
We'll see up road to high,
quickly slammed down.
Oof.
Sounded serious.
Like a cherry bomb exploded.
That's the two main blood vessels that in gorge for an erection.
Oh,
each one on east side of the main vein that pipes,
the swimmers that once a folded over can abruptly snap.
And my essence,
oh my butthole twin.
The blood float internally creating a big dark purple hog sausage and emergency
surgery pronto.
Fuck five days of morphine and,
and in the hospital,
Jesus as an aside,
having happened in San Francisco back in College,
going to SF general emergency means you're in a teaching hospital.
Ah,
yeah,
that's right.
It's a matter
gold.
So they're similar to Rodman's third break.
They hold so many fucking doctor in Hertz through to see the anomaly of a broken
dick.
It became a field trip of,
so here we have something you probably won't see again showcase of my dick with
a catheter in it.
Inside of a plastic tower of protection.
Awkward.
Too absurd to nonchalant to local legend in the inner circle of friends get well
cards from grandparents were a little awkward also.
Oh,
oh
wow.
I love y'all Seattle Fan.
Wow.
Oh,
oh yeah.
It's really loud.
It was like a big boat.
Neck broke one day,
like three times.
Yeah,
I mean from him.
I actually know that thinking about it,
I think I kind of believe it,
you know?
Oh No,
it's real.
No,
I believe it happened to him three times I'm saying.
Oh absolutely.
Especially when you're whacked out on drugs or whatever.
Hanging out with lunatics,
man.
Hanging out with friends.
No losers.
Fucking loser.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How great was it to hear your dad laughing at blonde jokes by the way?
And that,
you know,
we gotta do we,
it's got to be a regular you guys,
we need to just email us your blonde jokes and you're Polack jokes and then
we'll just tell them to him.
Yeah.
It's so great listening to him laugh at the dumbest jokes ever.
I called him by the way,
right after that call.
Cause remember when I go at how many people you kill,
he was like,
oh three I go,
what was that like?
And he's like,
I don't want it to,
I go,
dude.
I said,
you know,
I'd never would try to,
make you feel badly about that or put you on the spot about that.
I said,
you've talked about it publicly before.
Yeah,
because he,
we've had on the show.
Yeah.
It looks like sexual experience.
And he goes,
oh I know.
He goes,
it's just how that question question hits you in the moment.
So I just wanted to share that with listeners that I called him immediately and
he goes,
you know that question just in the moment you might not want to discuss it.
Which I think makes sense.
Of course are sometimes you don't want to talk about certain subjects.
And then immediately we talked about it for about 30 minutes and it wasn't
recorded,
which suck.
No,
it wasn't recording.
He was like,
there's no thrill.
Like I was like,
all right,
we're back on board.
So
thank God.
Get on the enemy.
So fun.
It was south right away.
He was just like,
there's just nothing like it.
He goes,
one time I had was marine great Marine College Texas
and I said,
uh yeah,
if you could,
uh,
if you could kill the enemy or get a piece of pussy,
what would you,
you father said this to me and I in the guys weird kill the enemy.
He was like,
that's what I like to hear.
Your great fucking marine.
And it was Tommy.
We were trying to kill.
They are,
I know they love it.
Marines love that stuff.
Love that as a personality type that that's,
that's what they do.
Good and thank.
Thank God for the Marines.
If you're wired that way people for a good cause.
You were thinking about the fact that your dad vacations where my dad was in war
and my dad was a great,
I love is so fucking hot.
I told him on that cargo younger,
his dad just got back a month in Vietnam.
It was Jesus Christ.
I go,
we were just talking about what it would take for you to go there for a month.
That's not happening.
Not Happening.
He's like,
I hate that place.
Of course you were in war.
There I go.
I'm,
I'm thinking about getting you a gift and maybe taking you there.
Like we can go Tommy Jane doe the day I,
we plane banked out,
it was looking over the side yard.
I was like Matt never see this fucking place again.
Well I imagine his experience was,
it's a little different than,
you know,
a club med in Danang or a dude.
Every time I bring it up I get new stories.
It's actually pretty fascinating.
I wish I could hear them.
I really wish you would.
Fascinating more stories.
I mean yeah,
tell me them though.
Yeah.
Cause their shit that you're like,
oh I think I've heard all the stories and then 40 minutes.
Yeah.
Shit,
I've never heard it cause he kind of sheltered you from the stories for many
years.
Time,
long time through that I brought,
I brought up to him that when I was a kid as to,
cause you know,
I didn't curse for a long time as a kid.
You guys didn't swear at your house.
Yeah.
You're that kind of family that never dropped the F bomb?
No.
What about,
what about Shit could you say?
Well there's a certain age for all those things.
So like I would hear shit
dammit.
But you know,
shit was like as far as it went in the house and my mom,
even when Chet Chet,
that was probably like that,
you know,
actually that was like,
that was them forever.
I mean,
my mom never said anything worse than Shit.
My Dad,
first time I heard him say fuck,
I was in high school at some and I was like probably high school,
maybe a junior when I heard him say it like an accident,
like oh fuck.
And I was like,
whoa.
I had never heard by that time I was already saying it,
but I had never heard him say it as a kid.
Probably a first time I started cursing regularly was probably not until middle
school,
maybe seventh,
eighth grade or something.
You know,
like when you've kind of boys being boys.
But before that I didn't curse and one time and I thought that was just like
such a crazy thing to say the f word.
Right.
And I asked her,
I go,
did you ever say the f word?
And I said,
no.
Have you ever said the f word?
And I was like nine years old and I still remember him going one time
I go when he goes in Vietnam and I was like,
Oh,
I reminded him that he was like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He doesn't remember that of course.
But I remembered clearly and I was like,
it must've been really bad.
And then I go,
can I go?
Yeah,
you just like really high.
And he goes,
I know it's a regular part of my fucking vocabulary.
Any CSOS about a lot and pussy with you now.
And like,
cause I've kind of watched this evolution of your relationship because when you
and I started dating,
you were 20 what?
You were 25 five.
Yeah.
And he was still kind of putting the parental yeah,
image on with you.
And then I remember one time you were like,
Dude,
my dad just talked about like in full Bush.
Yeah.
And that was a few years later that he likes full Bush and,
and I think of the whole thing is,
you know how you don't see your parents as people for a long time.
Yeah,
for sure.
And then over time I realized like this dude's a total savage,
you know,
and I mean,
he's the best guy,
but he's a savage.
So it's all like,
yeah.
He's like,
remember we did the blonde joke and he goes,
fucking broad stump Raj.
He can see a dumb broad doing that.
I love it so much.
It's such an old school,
like,
oh,
and I'll,
you know what?
And I kind of,
but I respect that and I kind of noticed that so much because at the end of the
day,
like your dad obviously has two daughters and a wife and he loves them to death,
treats them well.
And you know what I mean?
I just,
I dunno,
it feels familiar to me.
I like,
here's my dad right here.
He just sent me this.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Sounds a different Dick.
Can I read you a text message of from my dad?
Yeah.
He came back from Vietnam.
This weekend.
Yeah.
My father finally returned.
Um,
hold on.
Finally,
final return from Vietnam after being gone for like a month.
And in the course of him being gone,
I mean we baptized our son.
Yeah.
We're an escrow on a house and I had my embryos frozen.
Like those are the three major big things.
Life things.
He didn't ask about any of it,
like the whole conversation about him.
And then in the last few seconds I had to like interject and be like,
well,
oh by the way,
are you know Ellis is growing teeth yet?
Yeah.
Ellis has two teeth now and where we bought a house and this or that.
Anyway,
so I'm telling him the location,
you know,
and he goes,
oh.
And then he's texting me,
you know,
make sure you get everything fixed before you move in.
Beautiful House.
Now you're going to be happy there and it's our neighborhood where you grew up.
And I go,
yeah,
no shit.
Like in my head,
I'm like,
yeah,
of course asshole.
I remember where I grew up.
He goes,
well Ellis is going to grow up there now and the liquor store is close,
the one at this,
you know,
this cross street of Blah Blah Blah Blah Blah Blah.
Remember that's the one fun memory my father has at this neighborhood.
We're moving to remember the liquor store that we went to and I was like Yeah
Dad,
remember that liquor store?
Yeah.
Like that's a nostalgic moment.
That's the sweet memory.
Yeah.
My childhood because I used to go there a lot.
I wasn't a every day.
Yep.
That's where we would pick up a six or right.
That's right after work we go in and he gets to the 600 to 12 or whatever it is.
That's all I remember when you thought that that was just a normal thing.
Yes.
You're like that's not every character that 12 pack 12 or every day after day.
He picked me up from school and his,
um,
in his van he had a,
he was
a mechanic and a,
I was so embarrassed by that van cause it was greasy and stinky,
you know,
like,
uh,
some mechanics.
I mean,
not everyone,
but I'm like you,
I was so embarrassed with certain people.
I know certain era when they would dress certain ways,
I was like,
oh my God,
cool sweater.
Well my dad dress called,
but when he would show up in his mechanics uniform sometimes and it'd be like
Gracie,
and I'm like,
oh my God,
we're mechanics uniform.
I'm like,
I'm so embarrassed.
But that was rare and he'd just come from the shop to come get me,
you know.
But otherwise,
my dad always dress cool.
He's cool.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
you're all cool.
He's like that Italian guy,
but you know,
not that gay.
My parents showed up to see us in high school or Middle School,
the same way you would show up to see a,
uh,
a kindergartener.
The words like,
my dad would come and be like,
hey buddy.
And I was like,
Hey man,
I'm 15.
And you dial it down a little bit.
Super enthusiastic.
And I was like,
yeah,
he still is like that same way today,
Christina.
It's different now.
Now you're like,
oh,
okay.
It's like I'm doing now.
But Tommy was such a cute little shit still.
So
tell me just the cutest little boy,
Christina,
and he could puke on me.
Shit on me.
I didn't care.
Yup.
Gear.
This little boy.
Aww Shit.
Tommy was a kid.
It's a Harry is right here.
There's my dad.
Uh,
so weird.
He sounds different.
When you record,
it was back in high school.
What was the Lamest,
your dad,
what was his worst era of fashion or as he always worn the uniform of khaki.
Buttoned down.
No,
no.
My Dad is a conformist.
He is.
He liked people to follow the rules.
Cut your hair,
cut your hair hippy,
put on different shirt.
He would like.
He's never really critical.
Not Critical Dad,
but he was just looking at me and be like,
no genes can't work.
Jesus all right.
Yeah,
a collared shirt.
That's how he wants you to look.
You know I want,
I used to have scruff,
not a beer,
but a scruffy scruffy then like that and share that.
But your father's fashion I'm saying didn't change with the Times.
Right.
I'm assuming he always wore like a polo shirt,
a button down Khakis,
a belt.
He doesn't own t shirts like working out tee shirt but not like I'm gonna work t
shirt to just go.
I don't think I've ever seen,
no,
he doesn't own it.
Even when they came to visit us in La a while,
like a month ago,
I was like,
do you want to stop by the hotel and change into something more comfortable?
And he goes,
I am comfortable.
Always didn't even dress loafers,
you know like those ones.
Jeez.
He's the only worn tennis shoes,
you know,
like I say per workout or if or if like he goes to me like a long walking day.
He might wear some then,
but no,
will he wear shorts?
Like khaki shorts are still long pants?
No,
he worked khaki shorts in the,
in the,
yeah.
Yeah.
But pretty much,
and a button down,
if it's auto,
probably let's say a polo
on a cruise.
It's harder.
Yeah,
for sure.
Probably some neat higher socks,
you know,
hindsight.
Yeah.
Did he ever have hair?
No.
I mean,
and the,
no,
he didn't ever have here.
I mean,
he had hair,
he had the last remnants of it when they,
when he was getting married.
So I don't remember how old was he when they got married at 30.
Wow.
Yeah.
So he had a comb over then,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah.
Everybody was doing that in the 70s to flip it over it camouflage and say,
you can't tell somebody.
I used to always get mad when I was in high school and even college that he was
clearly bald,
you know,
he had the horseshoe,
but all these hairs on top and then I go,
why don't you just clean that for a clean look?
Because I think it looks better.
Like if you're,
you just clean the top.
And he was like,
no,
I don't do that.
And I used to always be like,
dude,
it'll look Tommy.
I like it.
Okay.
And he called him his survivors.
You know,
cause it's like a hundred hairs.
You go just clean that up.
It'll look and now I think he does it.
Yeah.
Now he does because I've seen this him chicken hair on top 25 years.
Wow.
You go along with that plan.
It doesn't like it.
Such a creature of habit.
I know,
it's funny cause I remember when he was here and then he sat on our recliner and
he had his caffeine free sugar free Diet Coke because Dad's can't have fun
anymore.
You can't drink anything fun,
none that tastes good.
And he was just in heaven watching CNN.
I know.
Flip side is your dad shows up in like tracksuits and shit,
you know,
light orange tinted shades and the hair is the others.
He's back.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh let it sit.
That's what he wore at my wedding and linen white suit,
gangster shit.
Super Eastern,
blocky.
My favorite is when I was about to go down the aisle with him and I had,
why ain't know my wedding dress?
And here you are at the front of the church and it's going to be the one of the
biggest moments of my life and I turned to him and I was like,
Oh my God,
Dad,
I hope I don't cry.
And he was like,
lab.
Would you cry?
Like,
okay.
All right.
Jeffrey Dahmer like no feelings.
I cry.
I was crying.
We both were crying and so emotional.
It's so dumb.
We're going to have sex with anyone.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There you go.
Anyways,
our dogs are getting groomed.
Rumor has it.
They're going to be so cute when I love when come back.
I hate when they put
all those gay bows on your dog though.
Yeah,
I know.
Can I take this shit off of the poor dog?
Lead my dog on.
Leave the dog alone.
A mass hole.
This lady is pretty fantastic.
Don't put bows.
She's yelling at this guy on a train.
That stuff.
Yeah.
Good.
And I'm hitting up.
How did
I love the looking down?
Oh yeah.
That's what your eyes see any job.
Do some freaky shit again and I'm a get up out this chair and I'm a boss show
where she wants
when you get off the motherfucking train.
So we fucking understanding job.
Whoa.
Good for her.
Yeah.
Good.
This is like that creeper at your spa.
It was rubbing his dog.
He was rubbing his balls.
Yeah.
You need a woman like that to straighten his ass.
Good for her.
Yeah.
I'm at one of those moods.
Apple.
Fuck you up on his tray.
I can't hear you though.
You fucking hit me.
Stop.
You get the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up off the tray with that freaky shit when his train stops,
you get the fuck off.
Do you want to see and I think I get it.
Say on this day and you miss all right ma'am.
We got on this.
I love it.
Eyes down.
Ignore what's happening.
That's what I would want to,
or you have to have several in New York,
right?
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Fucking picture on here.
I got saying I don't give a fuck if you get off this train with that.
Oh,
it's him.
Yeah.
Oh,
sorry.
I was terrified.
Fucking crazy.
Yes.
Silence.
Everyone slap it on your penis.
He you serious?
I love it.
You need to show it to you.
You got the right one,
honey,
because I'm a crazy big bullies me.
I love her.
Love her.
Yeah.
Core hard fucking car.
That's my girl core.
Yep.
That's what's up.
She needs to be on every fucking train,
every public place where it would be a good job for someone to have.
That's a great job.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that is,
that's true.
Just to call out perverts like that.
Oh,
I love it.
Yup.
Get the fuck off.
There you go.
Beat the shit.
Yeah.
You don't see that a lot because the shit out of you.
Good girl.
All right.
Jeans.
Anything
else you got?
I ain't gonna pick up the dogs.
All right.
Um,
we have a closing song.
It's called succulent Chinese meal by David Belasco.
Carl's Jr by our son Carl's Jr.
Thanks for listening.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com uh,
Thompson Jr com thousand ranch.com.
Of course,
patrion.com/mom patron that up slash mom.
Enjoy your week.
Thank you for listening.
We love you mommy.
Buy Jeans.
The jeans.
Okay.
Succulent Chinese meal.
A succulent shiny.
That's succulent.
Tiny,
tiny
succulent Chinese meal of succulent Chinese meal.
A succulent shiny,
succulent,
shining,
shining
democracy.
Democracy
is democracy.
Democracy.
Democracy
is democracy matters.
I see that.
You know,
I'm waiting to feed my peanut.
I see that you're
a fucking
peanut.
A succulent.
Tiny
succulent.
Succulent
farewell.
Jean.